hello Carnegie Mellon University we're
here at the Cohen University Center
where we're going to celebrate 2017
commencement with our friends families
and other students and I'm here to
announce this year's keynote speaker and
honorary degree recipients we are proud
to announce your 2017 commencement
keynote speaker president and CEO of
Hewlett Packard Meg Whitman and now the
honorary degree recipients the first is
Harvard professor of psychology
mahzarin banaji through next honorary
degree recipient and founder of the
Osher foundation Bernard Osher let's
hear some applause for native
Pittsburgher and visiting scholar at the
entertainment Technology Centre actor
Michael Keaton and finally two clips
first african-american librarian and our
honorary degree recipients Vivien
Davison Hewitt and last but hopefully
not least I'm the student speaker
Krystal Thomas
you